hey guys Ryan right over here
representing the real rejects you guys
are new to the channel well let me tell
you what we feature trailer reactions
after the reaction i do a trailer review
that's right what's better than watching
the trailer watching me watch the
trailer and then i do movie reviews and
there's some movie news that's covered
and some short films and sketches the
occasional vlog you know what why why
let me talk about this why don't the
fans tell you about the real rejects of
why you should check us out enjoy i'll
have the real rejects because ryan is a
pretty cool and funny dude with a big
ass dick
if you're kind of the one who's like
always getting rejected this right here
are the real reject is where you'll find
yourself comfortable and all that the
real rejects are foul melt sexually
crude and disgusting but I love it real
rejects block they combine some of my
favorite things movies reviews poop dick
and fart jokes all in one they're funny
in the awesome put together we'll go
subscribe to this page real reject real
reactions all day every day you guys may
be watching wheel reject now I mean it
the real rejects are one of my favorite
movie channels of all time I love the
funniness the raunchy humor they know a
lot of knowledge about movies for me
they've got great reactions and they
always react to things at the pan che
right Ryan subscribe to the real read it
because my man Ryan I love your videos
man I've been watching you for about two
years when you have 10,000 subscribers
just keep up the good work man love you
peace you guys don't meeting hilaria
keep up the good work Ryan based is [ __ ]
Goryeo reject its channel where I can
laugh I can watch these really funny
people do funny things they are the most
amazing channel ever you guys are down
just get to this channel get to the real
reject and watch some reactions they're
gonna get you off gonna make you happy
and they're gonna make you laugh and
it'll save your day the real rain checks
are the [ __ ] I love watching the real
rejects because I like all the reactions
the death of me i'm scared kind of a as
all the racist jokes a try amazed
because racism can still be funny the
real rejects some of the best reactors
out there are you guys are all totally
awesome and keep up the dick jokes you
guys all make my day
you did they inspire people to do what
they love they inspired you to get out
there be yourself also write write a
funny [ __ ] if you subscribe
today trust me you will never regret it
I love the real rejects because they're
relatable they're funny and the coolest
mother [ __ ] you'll ever see I love
the wheel rejects because they have the
funniest reactions and because they
would every count one word that
describes the real rejects is awesome
fantastical all right real rejects I was
gonna make gay joke but [ __ ] it I prove
they are awesome and they have like I
don't know funny stuff that's it I
started watching a couple weeks ago and
no stop why should every day I never met
a very entertaining to watch and evolve
is boom in a good mood after I watched
from nerve videos wanted to say I'm in a
huge fan for a while hope keep doing
what you're doing you know I love the
real rejects definitely cuz of Ryan
stick jokes hey guys I'm right right I
am will Brower reactors assemble hi and
welcome to the VOA Jax this is a really
funny general that everyone just lost
and I love it even though it's maybe
about it's really funny so thank you oh
hey guys Ryan's like everyone's favorite
I don't think once I heard the guy swear
no I don't think I've ever heard him say
anything sexist or racist misogynistic
or even homophobic the real rejects
channel my super awesome super cool
super funny super sad I'm a big fan
which rejects that's really funny you're
really honest reactions just a bunch of
funny stuff for you to be his stuff and
I just think they're really funny and I
think yeah I'd say there is funny the
real new tricks yes we are thinking
Edward they're so hilarious they're
different from anyone else bring a
uniqueness to reaction videos that you
don't really get from people like the
fine Bros their amazing funny sexy
awesome everything you
in life is pretty much all crammed up in
here it is really the best reaction
channel